اعلنت مديريه الدفاع المدني في العراق
اخماد حريق في مبنى يضم مخازن عطور بمنطقه
الوزيريه في العاصمه بغداد وقالت ان فرقها
تواصل البحث عن المفقودين في المبنى واكدت
وزاره الداخليه العراقيه ان اكثر من 10
اشخاص يعتبرون في عداد المفقودين مشيره
الى ان الحريقه قد اسفر عن اصابه مدير
الدفاع المدني وضابط بالمديريه وعشره من
رجال الاطفاء
الوزيريه وسط بغداد مراسل الجزيره سامر
يوسف سامر اهلا بك المزيد بشان ملابسات
هذه القضيه والاجواء حيث انت
بدايه سفيان يتوقع ان تستمر لساعات اخرى
هذه الاعمال للانتهاء من اخماد اللهب الذي
مازال يخرج من داخل هذه البنايه بحسب فرقه
الدفاع المدني التي تتوقع ان بضائع من
العطور ما زالت موجوده وهي تحترق طباعا
على الرغم من اعلان فرق الدفاع المدني همم
اخماد الحريق بشكل شبه كامل الا ان هذه
الاعمال ما زالت همم مستمره كما تشاهدون
امامكم هذا الموقع هو موقع همم تجاري همم
همم ملاصق لمنطقه همم سكنيه ولكن حيث ناقف
الان في هذا المكان هو مكان همم تجاري
لمحال تجاريه لمخازن ايضا تضم بضائع هذه
المحال بحسب فرق الدفاع المدني فان هذه
البنايه همم تقدر مساحتها
بنحو 500 متر همم 10 امتار
وبعمق 50 همم
كما واضح في الصوره هناك اليات ايضا همم
ثقيله تحاول احداث ثغره في جانب هذه
البنايه
لاخراج المفقودين حسب ما يقول همم ذويهم
بان لهم مفقودين في هذا المكان كانوا
يتواجدون في هذا همم المكان همم همم عنده
وقوع هذا همم الحادث المساحه التي تعرضت
للحرق بشكل كامل همم اقل من 1000 متر همم
بقليل هي همم مئات الامتار بحسب فرق
الدفاع المدني التي قالت ايضا
بانها همم تنتظر فرق الادله الجنائيه
لتحديد سبب رئيسي وراء هذا الحادث هذه
الفرق ستاتي الى هنا ستكشف عن الموقع بعد
الانتهاء من هذه الاعمال التي تشارك فيها
اليات ثقيله ايضا واا فرق من هيئه الحشد
الشعبي كذلك
شكرا لك سامر يوسف كنت معنا اذا من بغداد